[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
RAJEN SHETH: Thank
you, everyone.
Great to be here and
great to see you all here.
So I'm going to
talk a little bit
about the past, the present,
and the future of the cloud
and especially how
it relates to how
we access the cloud
and the devices
that we use to access the cloud.
So I'm going to
start with the past.
This is a very, very old Google
Apps logo, and so 10 years
ago-- right now,
this week-- we were
doing our very first customer
pitches of Google Apps.
And I remember it
very distinctly
because I flew to New
York with a little more
than a slide deck, with the idea
of talking to a bunch of CIOs
and trying to convince them to
move their email to our data
centers.
And the cloud wasn't even a
concept really at the time.
And people talk about
things like SaaS,
but the cloud really
wasn't a concept.
So we went up and down Manhattan
with about a dozen customer
visits, and I'll never
forget the very last one.
So we walk into a big
company, go to the boardroom
and talk to the CIO
of this big company.
He walks in.
I go to slide number
one, start to talk
about the concept of
what we're talking about.
And he stops me on
slide one, and he
says OK, let me
understand this, you
want me to move my data
to your data centers.
I said yes, and so he
says, he thought about it,
he gave me a quizzical
look, and he got up
and he said, I'm
sorry not interested
and just left the room.
And I was relatively young
product manager at the time,
and I was just stunned.
My brand new product here--
the guy didn't want it.
Nobody wanted it.
And so I kind of started
thinking, maybe I'm crazy.
Maybe this thing isn't
really going anywhere.
What have I gotten myself into?
Well, it turns out
it wasn't that crazy.
And turns out this cloud thing
may have a future here as well,
too.
But in all seriousness,
it's amazing to see kind
of in the 10 years
that's passed,
how much the cloud has evolved.
It's gone from something
that's been on the fringe
to something that's mainstream.
And we've gone from the concept
of thinking about what can you
do on one, two, and three
servers to what can you
do on a 1,000 servers or 10,000
servers or 100,000 servers.
And it opens up a whole
set of new possibilities.
One of the most
profound transitions,
though, has been in
the devices that we
use to access the cloud.
So I think about that
meeting 10 years ago,
and we were all walking in with
laptops, and all of my data
was on that laptop.
If I lost that
laptop, I wouldn't
be able to do any work any
more, whereas now we move
from device to device device.
We can have low-powered,
hand-held devices
where I can access all
the world's information.
I can access every
email I've ever written,
every document that's
ever been shared to me,
every photo I've ever
taken, every song
I've ever listened to.
Things like that are just
absolutely astounding,
and it's all because
of the cloud.
And so the question is that
now where do we go from here,
and how do we make it
such that everybody
has access to the cloud.
So the question I
want to pose to you
is what would happen if
everyone in your business
had access to the
cloud at all times.
And when I say
everyone, I don't just
mean the people with desks.
I mean every employee, and I
don't just mean every employee,
I also mean what about
your customers too.
People that might walk into
a storefront, for example.
What would happen if everybody
had access to the cloud?
So imagine if that
were the case.
So I'll take the example
which you just saw.
Imagine if every student in a
school had access to the cloud
at all times.
You could transform
how a school works.
You can take curriculum,
and you can cater it
to the needs of
every single student.
You can actually bring
in interactive content
that would be incredibly
engaging for the student.
And we've seen this now happen
where test scores are going up,
where engagement is going
up, and students are learning
in a very different way.
Imagine if you had a
store, and in that store,
every customer that walked
in and every employee
had access to the
cloud at all times.
The customers can walk in
and have engaging experiences
with kiosks, for
example, where they
can access all the
information they need
to research their purchase.
They'll know about things that
are on the shelf and things
that may not be on your shelf.
And they'd be able to
make a purchase decision
and actually build loyalty
and engagement in a much
better way.
Your employees will have quicker
access to knowledge of anything
that they need and be able
to serve the customer better.
And processes that used to be
on paper, can now be automated.
Things like everything from
HR processes, to time cards,
to ship scheduling, can
all be automated processes.
Things like that-- that can
really transform a business
and create business value.
But the truth is that
that's actually not what's
happening right now.
So there are about 3.2 billion,
3.25 billion workers that
walk into a workplace every
single day, but about 75%
of those workers
don't have a desk.
And there are only about 750
million PCs in business today,
too.
And as much as we talk
about the smartphone,
even though there are almost
2 billion consumers that
have smartphones, there
are only about 300 million
manage smartphones
in businesses today.
And so we need to do more to try
to make that vision take root,
to bring the cloud
to more people.
So this is really
what we've been
thinking about with
our device platforms.
And so Chrome OS and
Android, the great thing
that we've been
able to do is we've
been able to grow up in
the age of the cloud.
These operating
systems were started
in the age of the cloud.
So we could design
it from the ground
up with the cloud in mind.
And as a result of
that, we can extend it
to the future of where
devices are going.
And that future really
falls into three buckets,
and this is what we're
focusing on in terms
of how do we actually
evolve our products.
The first is mobility for all.
How do we bring the idea of
mobility to every single user?
Second is redefining the
concept of productivity.
The PC is something that is
evolving extremely rapidly,
and it's still very
important, but important
a very different
way, and I'll go
into kind of what that means.
And the third thing
is beyond mobility.
How do we actually
go beyond mobility
and actually start to bring
this to new devices that
are very different?
So the first part about
bringing mobility to all.
The key lesson here is that
one size doesn't fit all.
You can't just have one
type of mobile device
that is the same for
everyone, that you
might give, for
example, to your CEO,
but then you also might
give to, for example,
somebody on the shop floor.
And this is the thing we've
really focused on with Android.
How can we have the
operating system be the same,
but how do we make it such that
there are a plethora of devices
that are out there?
So with Android, the
great thing we have is we
have almost 1,000 OEMs that
are actually building devices
of all kinds of various types.
And these are just a few of
the examples that are there.
And there are very,
very premium devices,
there are inexpensive
devices, there are tablets,
there are big phones,
there are small phones,
there are rugged devices--
all kinds of things
that would actually
make it such that it
fits the particular
business need that you have.
A great example of this is
this contrast right here.
So on one side you
have the Nexus 6P,
which you all got today.
We took care to put the most
premium materials in there,
the best possible
camera we can find,
display we can find,
making it such that it's
an incredible experience
for the top-end user.
On the other side, you have
a phone that DeWalt produced.
And DeWalt, as many of you know,
produces construction tools,
but they actually
also produced a phone.
And this phone meets
the needs of what's
needed for a construction
worker on the job site
at a particular time.
This is the kind of phone that
you can drop from a building,
and it will be safe.
You can dump it a vat of
water, and it'll be safe.
It has a set of
peripherals on it
that are needed for
the construction site.
For example, you'll
be able to actually do
measurements using this phone.
Things like that are very
specific to that need.
And with Android, you have that
plethora of areas out there.
This is the kind of area we're
looking forward to evolving.
How can we meet the
needs of more employees?
We're very excited
about the partnership
we announced earlier today
with Accenture in mobility
that we can now start to go
after very specific use cases
and start to bring mobility as
a much bigger part of those use
cases.
The second part is how
do we redefine the PC.
And so one exercise that we
took is, if we redefined the PC,
what would it be.
If we had to start
from the ground up,
what would that--
what would that be
and how would we look
at it differently?
So the first three
things we thought of
is that it needs to be fast.
You need to be able to get into
what you're doing very quickly
and start being productive.
It needs to be easy.
And it needs to be secure
from the very get-go.
You shouldn't have to be
worrying about viruses,
and playing whack-a-mole
with viruses.
It should just be
secure from the get-go.
And so that's how we designed
Chrome OS to begin with.
But then three other
things-- we thought
it needed to be shareable
because in a world where you're
using many devices, you
may not want to give
a PC to every single person.
You want to make it such that
you have a bank of devices
that people can use
whenever they need to.
You want to make it
get better over time.
The wonderful thing
about the cloud
is that it just gets
better over time.
Gmail-- we'll ship a new
feature every single week,
and make it better
and better and better.
Why isn't your PC like that?
It needs to be like that.
And the last thing is that
it needs to be versatile,
meaning that you need to be able
to use it as a mobile device,
but you also need to be able
to use as a productive device.
It needs to switch
whenever you need to.
So two aspects I want to
drill into a little bit--
the shareability.
This has been one thing that has
really made Chromebooks very,
very successful in US schools.
And so Chromebooks now
represent about 60%
of the devices that
are in US schools,
and we've seen an enormous
amount of impact there.
But the way that
started is a teacher
would buy what we call here
a Chrome cart with about
30 Chromebooks, roll
it into the classroom.
When the class starts, a
student would go and pick up
any Chrome, open it up, log
in, and within five seconds
they're into their applications.
They do what they need
to do in the classroom,
return it at the end of the
class, the next class walks in,
and then the next set of
students pick that up.
So within a day you
might hit 180 students
with the same set
of 30 Chromebooks,
and so scenarios
like this really
open up the
possibilities what you
can do with even less budget.
So a great example of this
is East Leyden High School
so East Leyden High School did
this with their science classes
in Chicago.
And they now are
using Chromebooks
to let their students be
able to actually design
artificial limbs and be
able to actually then go
and produce them.
And so it's the
kind of experience
that I know I never
had in school,
but is now possible
because of the technology
that they have
there and the fact
that every student has access to
that technology in that science
class.
But we're now starting to see
this within businesses as well.
So a great example
of this is what we're
doing with Charles Schwab.
So Schwab had a problem
where they wanted
to bring more devices
into their branch offices,
and they also wanted to have it
such that those devices would
be very easy to
manage and low cost
and have it such that
they could use it
but they could also have
the customers use it.
So they brought
Chromebooks in, and what
they're doing with it is that
when you walk into a Schwab
office and you want to
actually open an account,
rather than handing you a
stack of papers which we're all
used to, they'll hand
you a Chromebook.
You open and you actually
have your own private, secure
session.
You'll be able to fill out
the information right there
securely, submit
it and you're done.
And there's no-- there's
no manual process that
needs to happen.
And so they've found that it's
more satisfying for the users,
and it's actually a lot
more efficient for them.
That's just one example,
but they're actually now
able to share that
Chromebook between customer
to customer to customer because
of the shareability of Chrome
OS.
So the second thing
I want to emphasize
is this idea of
mobile productivity.
So when you think of the
devices that are out there,
a lot of times you have to
choose between either being
mobile or being productive.
And so you have
tablets out there
that have a vast array
of mobile applications,
but then they don't
have the ability
to really be productive-- have
multi-windowing, multitasking,
be able to let you do a
lot of things all at once.
Or you can choose a PC where
you are very, very productive,
but you don't have those
mobile applications
that are out there.
And so this is kind
of the next frontier
that we're going
after with Chrome OS.
We announced last week
that Chromebooks will now
have Android apps
running on them,
and the entire Google Play Store
now runs on the Chromebook.
So the two million plus apps
that we have out there will run
on the Chromebook seamlessly.
And so what this opens
up is the possibility
for many more types
of devices that
can be both a mobile device
and a productive device.
This is an example of the
ASUS Chromebook Flip, where
you can turn it into
a tablet and you
can turn it into a laptop.
When it's in a laptop mode
you have multi-windowing.
You can do all the types
of desktop applications
you want-- with things
like virtualization,
you can be able to access
Windows applications as well.
But then you flip
it into a tablet,
and you have all of the great
Android applications that
are out there that make
it a great mobile device,
and so it's no compromises.
Lastly, how do we
go beyond mobility
and what do we do there?
So the first thing
that we're doing here
is how do we light up every
screen in your business.
And so, give you
another example of this.
So this is an example
from a convenience store.
You'll notice the board
up there is an ad,
and it's a promotion that
they have in the store.
We've now made it
such that it's easier
to make that a digital sign,
and it's actually cheaper
to make than a digital sign
than to make a paper sign.
We released this thing last year
called The Chrome Bit, which
is an $85 little dongle that
you stick into a screen,
and it turns it into a
sign or a full computer.
And so we're now having it such
that people are now thinking,
can I take any paper
sign I have and turn it
into a digital sign.
Rotate through the right
promotions at the right time,
depending on what
inventory I want to push
at that particular time.
And so one example of this
that we're working with
is Coca-Cola.
So Coca-Cola just
announced a set of pilots
with Albertsons stores.
What they are going to be doing
is in about 750 Albertsons
stores in the drink
aisle, they'll
be putting a 10
inch Chrome screen.
It'll be a Chrome digital sign.
They can control that centrally
and push out whatever promotion
they want to those signs.
The other interesting part
is that on top of that sign
there will be an
Eddystone beacon.
And when an Eddystone
beacon does--
is it broadcasts a URL
from that particular sign.
So when a consumer goes
into that drink aisle,
and says you know there's a two
for one special on Coke Zero,
they can pick out
their phone, they'll
have a URL that will be
there waiting for them.
They can click on that
URL, and get that coupon,
and use it at the checkout
stand immediately.
And Coke can actually
rotate that on a daily,
or even the
minute-by-minute basis,
depending on what
they want to do.
And so it opens up a whole
set of new possibilities.
The next part of this is what
about the kinds of devices
that aren't just mobile devices
and go beyond that to things
like wearables.
So a few examples here.
There are things like
watches that can be there.
There are things
like, for example,
other types of specialized
devices for particular areas,
like barcode scanners,
various things like that.
There is a whole exciting
area around things
like augmented reality
and virtual reality.
So think about
augmented reality where,
if you give that to a
field service worker,
the phone can actually guide
them through a very complicated
repair by actually
seeing what's there
and being able to point out
to them exactly what they
need to do.
Those are things
that are now going
to be possible with Android.
But the exciting thing
is all of these devices
that we can't even
dream of today,
and we're preparing for
that world as well too.
We have a project
called Brillo which
is looking to bring
Android and take Android
into these types of new devices
and give you a platform that
can extend to that.
And we have a
project called Weave
that gives you a communication
protocol between these devices
and makes it so that there's
a standard way for data
flow from those
devices into the cloud
and let you be able to actually
make the internet of things
a reality.
So the world of devices,
this is kind of where
I see things going you know.
This could be the dominant
set of devices in five years
out there.
So last thing want to
talk about is the future.
This is my daughter Siona.
She just started
first grade, as you
can see from her little sign.
She came to me a few weeks
ago, and as many of you
guys can relate to,
I tried to tell her
what I do for a living.
And she kind of gets that I
build computers and phones,
but she mostly thinks I
just go to meetings all day.
But a few weeks ago she
came to me and said, daddy,
can I use a Chromebook.
I said, where did
you learn about this.
She said, yeah, I want to log
in with my Google Apps account.
I said, oh my god,
this is crazy.
And so, it turns out, at her
school they have Chromebooks.
They use Google Apps for a
lot of the things they do.
She's able to log in
and actually personalize
her math lessons or her reading
lessons on a Chromebook.
She uses a thing called
i-Ready to be able to do math
at her own pace.
She has this thing
called RAS kits which
she can use at home to be able
to actually read books and read
from a massive library of
books anytime she wants.
Things like that I never
had when I was a kid,
and I think about the
kinds of things she does.
She expects that
anywhere she is she
can be able to actually listen
to any song that she wants.
Or that she can say,
OK, Google, and be
able to actually get
any fact that she
wants at any point in time.
The amazing thing is
15 years from now,
she'll probably
be in the employee
of one of our companies here.
15 years from now she'll be
probably a customer for many
of her companies as well, too.
We as change makers are building
the world for people like her
and all of our kids, where
the cloud is just intrinsic.
It's always there.
And so the challenge
for us is how do we
make that world take shape.
And I think with
the technologies
that we have in the mindset
that all of you have,
we can make that happen.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]